[Music]
whoa
[Music]
and we are live
good evening storm actually good
afternoon stormy bear for you thank you
very much uh you should be in bed young
man
i know i should i should the wife's gone
but um i i've stayed up to talk to all
you lovely people
so um
yeah mostly you stormy
so um good evening happy new year sir
this is the first time we have spoken
since
2022 began
by 2021 you absolute [ __ ] of the year
don't jinx it what are we gonna do
so like the twenties like the swinging
twenties back in there you know and
everything was awesome and uh
the twenties two thousand and twenties
has been shocking
it's uh it's not been the same
no but oh well
so
i just thought i would get us together
have a little bit of a chin wag and um
first of all i've got it i've got to
talk about this
most most recent of my cock-ups
on um on my on my side track channel
that i i did a little video that
actually had a really interesting story
in it because you know say um
i i love stargate it's my favorite
sci-fi show ever
um i think it's i think it's the best tv
show and hopefully it's coming back and
uh amazon are buying mgm
and amazon have actually got stuck in
the regulators the regulators have
decided that they don't really want
amazon to buy mgm amazon is bad amazon
doesn't pay taxes
um so
they're
bummed up the um the processor
so
amazon have agreed that they will
actually base all of their productions
in future in the united states of
america
um and that way they pay taxes and they
get jobs and this is a bit of a backroom
deal sort of thing but it
it'll allow them maybe to move on with
the sale and maybe get mgm so we're
doing a bit sooner
unfortunately that's quite an important
story i thought you know it's like
actually quite a big deal for um for
stargate we might get stargate a spit
sooner thing
but i stupidly put a picture of a man's
tapping uh wrapped in an american flag
on the thumbnail
now i remember that coming out and
people getting quite angry about it
because she's not american she's
canadian she's actually british canadian
he's got a british dad and canadian mom
i think all the other way around
um
so
she actually ended up apologizing for it
i never really thought that was still a
problem
but also some people got upset
and then a couple of people said i was
sexist and derogatory to women but i
didn't think so i thought it was okay i
just was a cheeky joke um but a couple
of people got quite annoyed
i just wondered did you see the thing
did you think i was a silly billy oh
no it was you know
i'm trying to remember
the where the the photo originally came
from it was um
it's from a promotional piece i thought
in like people magazine or something
i thought it was like one of those
blokes magazines that appeared i think
that's where we saw it in the uk
um was in like um well they had silly
names like nuts magazines and things
like that that we we are over here but
it might not be the same over there it's
the same
or something
yeah yeah we're at fhm yeah exactly yeah
um don't exist anymore i wonder why um
tumblr
yeah but i didn't think it was
necessarily i didn't think it was
you know it was
um i'm just one i mean you know was it
the fact that it was titillating
everyone was upset or is the american
flag or she was canadian
or
or was just you know item 4218 of things
americans want need to be upset about
i don't know i think it's possibly that
last thing
and but i've actually generally lost
subscribers over and i do seem to have
upset a few people so i've actually took
the video down but also more importantly
i thought actually i was trying to say
something that was quite important i
thought about you know my favorite tv
show maybe coming back and it was
getting drowned out by people yelling
about amanda tapping's boobs
so um i thought i better take it down so
anyway i've took the video down and i've
done it again so i'll just put it back
up
without
you know
put the same thumbnail
and
and you know with uh that and just title
it amanda tapping's boobs and then just
have i don't know just live stream video
of prairie dogs or something just
nothing related to
you know or in the video i actually made
a joke out of it yeah i'm joking how
many people really clicked just because
of the thumbnail um so i thought it was
okay i thought it was just cheeky but
anyway i just wondered what your opinion
was because uh
i'm not astonishing anything stupid
anymore i'm just i just can't
yeah yeah your volume isn't amazing by
the way mate but
never mind
man yeah
i've got aliens in space saying listen
we know we're not a weirdo actually you
you don't know me that well
i'm like 30 weirdo
but i think it's like
yeah maybe some other area but i think
it's like it's it's it's an okay weirdo
it's it's it's okay that i'm a little
bit
nuts but um it's it's a healthy nuts i
think
anyway mate as we're in the new year i
thought we'd have a little bit of a chat
and by the way if anybody's watching
wants to join our conversation you can
you can come in and have your own little
window um and you can just sit back so
there's a link in the description we
would love to meet a few people so if
you want to come and say hello you're
more than welcome just try and have
something to talk about when you come
if you if you'd like if nobody joins
because you're scared that's fine as
well
okay
so um
2021 all right let's restart that what
have you
enjoyed of 2021 or what did you uh
absolutely hate of 2021.
just like star trek discovery straight
out
oh well you know the let me start with
the things i enjoyed uh foundation on
apple plus yeah that was very well done
i thought uh i was curious how they were
gonna adapt the books
to television they did a very good job
um it was beautifully made
absolutely beautifully made yeah i tell
you what mate we actually have a
chap wanting to join us so why don't we
just say like hey
my friends how are you hello
tell us your name aliens in space and
where you from
me uh i'm from florida over here and uh
well for now you can i'll i'll tell you
guys in private but i i can't take
aliens inspiration
there's no bother at all but you guys
want to see something cool
you guys want to do something cool dude
you have an amazing collection that is
awesome oh you suck that's awesome
that is actually genuine what else you
got there man you got a few things
yeah uh that's the lost in space robot
uh from
the
99 movie back there i don't know if you
guys can see it yeah yeah the um leblanc
movie that was amazing
but uh you know they made a stargate toy
back in the day
that they only sold through the magazine
previews
and if you look on ebay those figures
are going for like hundreds of dollars
yeah no i know i know again i saw at
original o'neill go for like 400 quid
over here
wow
look
look wait
wait wait
we're only going to full choice dude you
kept them in the box as well
so we got a glider
amazing i can't quite see what that
is from the movie
no way dude you got a collection there
is this your retirement fund
no but you know if you guys are into
stargate uh they got good prices on the
kenner figures
so i got the whole kenner collection for
a hundred and thirty dollars
that is very cool
a lot of the new starship models have
come out recently and they look pretty
pretty wicked
you know there's the x302 and if the
models that are pretty stunning uh i
like the ships and things i'm a bit of a
trekkie as well i love stargate loves
star trek i love the ships i just think
they're
amazing eagle mods those are what
they're called very yes yes that's right
yeah
yeah very cool you are a proper
connoisseur and that is a hell of a
collection
that is the collection
i'm married i'm not like that
thank you thank you thank you hey you're
very welcome thank you for joining us so
um so you're a big stargate fan then so
what do you think about the possibility
of stargate coming back do you think
it's a possibility or uh
i i am so excited because
re-watching stargate you know it's weird
because a lot of normal people that are
aren't into
uh marvel or are into video games but
they're into star game you know because
it was on tv they were able to catch it
uh
it's so surprising to me that stargate
isn't selling merchandise more
merchandise you know
um
it just boggles to me and um
you had mentioned in one of your videos
that was one of the most profitable
franchises that mgm has the second most
profitable franchise that they own yeah
it's only after bond james bond is the
only thing that's made him more money
you know i'm excited second to james
bond yep second to james
the original stargate movie is the 10th
highest grossing mgm film of all time
that's just the movie the mind
series whoa
they need to be getting the gold mine
for them and you know it's like uh let's
not pay attention to it
you know
i i don't understand their their
business
uh their their
business philosophy of keeping it down i
mean i would have had that
i mean i get that that they had the
streaming service the quasi streaming
where you could just you know watch
you know stargate stuff but
they really missed an opportunity i mean
they missed out on
what lifetime billions in revenue
don't even get me started well it's like
amazon keep
like saying i i've been talking to
somebody a couple of people who work for
mgm and a couple of guys a guy that
works close to mgm and apparently amazon
they keep calling the sleeping giant of
sci-fi and that's what how they keep
describing it and um and that's
apparently one of the things when the
amazon
deal started one of the things they kept
talking about apparently it was target
that the mgm realized that they were
interested in stargate really early on
and um and it makes sense to me because
i mean other than after star trek star
wars i would say it's one of the large
biggest franchises
out there the most popular yeah and you
look at facebook groups and things like
that people actually talking about this
stuff
it's star trek star wars star gate
firefly
are the things people seem to talk about
the most
um amazon ain't stupid they look at that
they realize what people are talking
about and that's what they they're
interested in so yeah amazon stupid if
this is coming back it's just a matter
of when
and how badly they [ __ ] it up i'm sorry
i actually told people if you do come on
don't swear
you know i was gonna say one of the
things uh that i
they cannot top the pilot
to sg1 uh
i think i was commenting on one of your
videos because it was like a story out
of heavy metal magazine
i don't know if you guys ever read the
comic of heavy metal magazine
uh not over here in the uk i'm afraid no
we didn't have that
it's a uk magazine
oh i missed that now i didn't see that
and
mobius had oh i'm sorry no i'm thinking
of 2018d
but this sg-1 was like heavy metal
because over here in the states there
was a sci-fi comic magazine called heavy
metal
and it had a lot of like beautiful women
and like the conan you know the old
conan's and um
uh that's what it reminded me of the the
scientist and the pilot the wife
remember because it was on show time so
they had shown nudity
uh
but the other seasons had gone to sci-fi
so
it wasn't they couldn't get as adults
but yeah you could see the range
uh
that they were going for in that
original pilot you know
yeah i've talking about this in another
video and i'm saying about how the the
feel of the first um double episode was
really the style was very similar to the
movie in loads of ways i mean the
starting sequence was the same and
things like and that was something brad
right apparently hated they they didn't
want to use the opening sequence but
they didn't have any money you know they
had the crossover mummy the sarcophagus
cross-eyed at the start
oh i don't remember that yeah
if you actually watched the original
side start again they stopped because
the eyes are too close together so it
looks like they're crossed it's really
once you know it's all you can see
um but yeah brad wright apparently hated
that he didn't want it at all um
but they didn't have any money so but
there was very much a feeling they
wanted to like bridge between the two
but apparently um richard dean anderson
had actually contractually
had um how he wanted his character to be
he wanted to be a bit wise cracking and
he wanted to be o'neill that we know and
love
but they said well that's not what
o'neill's like in the film
so we've got to sort of like ease that
in a little bit and that's why you see
in the first series he doesn't
he doesn't crack a lot of jokes and he's
not like the o'neill we love but by the
end of the first series he is and it's
because they they they steadied it out
obviously they wanted to bridge between
the two sort of things
the way they did it i guess in writing
that i really did appreciate concerning
that topic
is that over the first season they they
played up to him healing from the loss
of his son
have you noticed that i mean you know
from at least
they they gave it some service in the
very first you know a bit of that season
and then you see him just kind of
coming to grips
with that issue
and
i guess allowed himself to mourn as he
saw there was something more important
that he could be doing now for the
memory of his son yeah i mean
started again didn't they a couple of
times they touched on it again a couple
of times
he
doesn't maybe and then it kind of gives
you the idea that in the movie this was
the
the ptsd version of uh o'neill that we
saw in the movie and then we see him
heal over time at least that's the way i
saw it
yeah it was definitely well he was
suicidal at the start of well
yeah i mean you know
that's why he was pictures because he
was willing to blow himself up yeah so
willing to nuke himself
most definitely
but um what do you think about
the i mean cause i've seen this big
story that brad wright's version that he
wants to bring back
um is going to be something like a
stargate academy basically because it
will be a new sg team just coming out of
the academy during the end threshold
episode oh when we saw um some young sg
trainees sort of thing um
i'd be interested to see if one of those
might come back maybe
what do you guys think do you think that
would be something you'd want to watch
dude anything with gate i mean you know
i would i would be interested in
watching so i really do love this i mean
you know it's like
you know stargate vacations you know
just you know
i would just dig that i mean there's so
many things they could do with that idea
i mean it's just
give me just tourist commercials of
stargate location and i would
watch that you
you've only gotta know about a thousand
miles north and you can see him
what what happened
i was like because obviously he lives in
california he could just go north and go
to british columbia and he could wander
around all the the uh
yeah
oh yeah what do you think though about
aliens what do you what do you think do
you want to see like a stargate academy
or would you rather see something a bit
more
sort of established
you know if there's anybody who should
continue the stargate thing it should be
brad wright you know
um
because
the way they ended universe and there's
a whole mythology there
that he had set up for years and
there's such a huge audience you know
still
of all ages for it
and you know i thought amazon was all
about cutting costs you know and and
making money and stuff
so you know if they bring him back
and they have a stargate academy they
have their diverse cast
you know in the academy because you have
all these different students from all
these different backgrounds
and then you have the stargate mythology
and people are gonna wanna buy
uh merchandise because you know if you
have a franchise you wanna
sell things for it
so i'm surprised they're not jumping on
that because they tried katherine
and you know
catherine didn't last seven seasons or
ten the origins wasn't great was it
really
well and then again i think it was very
low budget and a bit of an attempt at
mgm to do like an online
it didn't it didn't work
yeah
so what do you think about the rumors
then that maybe amazon might move away
from brad right
they might try to bring in somebody new
some new ideas that that's okay too i'm
open to that
you know it's you know i mean i think
that'd be fun it's just you always have
that fear
of
the new guy coming in and not really
understanding i mean it's the same kind
of fear we had with the uh the reboot of
uh battlestar galactica
with ronald moore you know ronald moore
very very capable writer and showrunner
well here's this thing that everyone's
loved since the seven well maybe most
people's left since the 70s and and you
know and it
he took control over it then we saw his
product and oh my god it was 20 times it
was amazing and probably still some of
the
sci-fi has ever produced for television
is ronald moore's uh battlestar
galactica
so you always have to be a bit different
though isn't interesting because there
was like 20 years between the two they
were very dated and obviously he was uh
he was allowed to basically take the
original idea and go his own way with it
slightly yeah sure he kept enough sorry
let's just say siri off
um he's he was allowed to sort of keep
keep chunks of the original to keep the
original fans happy but then he was
allowed to change stuff i think if a new
guy comes in with stargate with that
summer freedom
stargate fans might lynch him okay
um
so i think that's that's my problem is
on one hand i can completely see how
like a like a a hard reboot or a semi
hard reboot
would work and be good for writers
because it allows them to
be more creative because they haven't
got a load of cannon they've got to
worry about
that's true but i think i would
personally lose my
lose my craft if they did a hard reboot
um i don't i don't see what the point in
doing it really
just i know all sg-1 out the window no
can't do it
and even in you know even in
international countries like south
america and asia they played stargate
reruns so you have like a lot of
people from
you know different monetary
you know uh
poor people rich people all types of
people
watch those old stargates you know so
with like spiderman bringing all the
past movies all these franchises they're
bringing all the past people
uh i would have thought oh man why why
wouldn't they do that right with the
multiverse and going through wormholes
uh why not do that with the stargate
stuff you know they've got that option
but they've already seen
understanding if they were going to do a
reboot
so i'm not going
did he freeze oh we're losing him aliens
got him
i always just fell into space maybe
we'll see if he pops back
i'll drop you back for now and then
we'll see yeah
if you fancy me oh okay there's that
stargate you know where they open the
gate and there's this team on the other
side when there's a
black they're circling a black hole and
there's that time dilation he got stuck
in the time knowledge he's really living
in real time but we only see one frame
per year or whatever yeah yeah as i say
also at the end of the first series we
saw the episode where he went in daniel
went into a mirror universe so we know
there are multiple dimensions and there
is a multiverse within the stargate
universe i just find it a bit lazy i
don't want them to do what they did with
star trek
you know and say like okay we're going
to change all this stuff
he's back with us oh good there we go
that's all he escaped the black hole
welcome back
welcome back sir
um but you know they did that with star
trek and they went into a multiverse
thing and they went oh it's okay we've
changed time so anything that we now do
that messes with cannon we're not really
messing with canada don't worry about it
that's right there's a trekkie that
drove me up the freaking wall have you
seen the latest episode of discovery i'm
not watching it
i'm i'm digging my heels in
so
they didn't they took it off
amazon and then they put it on this
channel called pluto over here in the uk
but it's only at certain times it's like
an old-fashioned like tv
right right right so unless i'm watching
it at nine o'clock on a monday night or
something i can't watch it
and i'm like i'm not i'm i'm not
watching tv at your schedule so it's
like i want to binge watch it you best
so
went to watch it yesterday i sat down to
watch it um and i actually put a little
comment on um on the community page but
i'm going to watch it
and i got a bunch of people going don't
bother
yeah i was looking at the comments there
that was funny
and everybody was right because the the
comments were like
once you turn on the show it's like oh
remember that thing remember that thing
uh well forget about it that thing
and uh
like
for example uh in in star trek
though all the things about the borg and
the shields you know the borg whenever
for example you would shoot them with a
laser you'd shoot them once it would
would hit them and then they would
absorb
any uh laser attack you would have from
them yeah
but
in the movie first contact in the
beginning all those starships are are
attacking the borg ship
and it explodes that borg ship didn't
have that absorbing power that it had in
the show
and that's kind of like what discovery
is like but like 10 times worse you know
it's almost like every other line
is supposed to get a star trek fan mad
almost it's like
they want to get you mad it's almost
like
and it's it's not only me because i
thought oh maybe this is only me maybe
this show is just not for me but i
actually saw this with other fans
and uh
they were like
i can't even watch it i ha i have to
turn it off because
and these are like lifelong star trek
convention people who've gone to
conventions and stuff and yeah i
consider myself a trekkie i love star
trek
but i i stopped watching discovery
halfway through the second series um
because i got bored
um i then i did go back to it because
the third series was quite good i quite
enjoyed it then i thought well i'm gonna
have to watch the second series next i
don't really know what's going on
so i did go back
but then by the end of the fourth being
the third series
i'm bored again
this isn't this one thing it's not
it's not that it's like somebody said to
me goes oh well what's the difference
between good track and bad track no such
thing because it's just track and i'm
like no
there's good tracking there's bad
tracking
um you know you can go through the
movies can't you um
okay great terrible great great you know
they take in turns being great movie
terrible movie um unfortunately there is
bands and i just don't i don't like this
this this current generation picard
started brilliantly
and by the end of it it was a complete
[ __ ] show
um bad cg i couldn't even finish it i
couldn't even finish it just watch the
first step just what's the very last
episode just for just like
it's just bad
um
the ships were horrible and and it's
just like
you know you're saying about how they
almost like wrote it to annoys trekkies
that's how i feel about the last episode
of just like they did it to annoy us
they say let's do some ugly badly
designed ships because trekkies don't
care about that sort of thing and i'm
just going look at the state of that
freaking ship and it's like because
truckies do care about things like that
we really like the ships and stuff and
then we're geeks that's what we like
um
and then the battery was this hole
opened up and some tentacles came out
you know i'm just how [ __ ]
no
it's just too you know which one i
recommend is the expense
i was going to say yes the expanse
excellent series we were saying about
how amazon are just about the money
the only real evidence we've got to give
us an idea what they might do with
stargate i think is the expanse
they you know the expanse got cancelled
on cbs i think um amazon bought it and i
would say they've done a lovely job with
it they've just given them the money
and let the creators create
you know they've given them a decent
budget and just gonna crack on with it
if they do the same with stargate
i'm happy
well you know if we want to take that
analogy further to like
some of the fantasy they're doing
you know i was a big fan of wheel of
time from uh robert jordan
um
and after he died he did like 10 book
the 11 books on the series and he died
of cancer then brandon
sanderson of the mistborn series came in
and finished the
the next three books which finished the
series
so all the fans again had to oh my god
or is amazon going to [ __ ] it up is it
going to be horrible is it going to be
whatever and
it did need more budget but they did a
very good job of telling the story you
know bringing it to film and
that is
if if you've ever read any of the wheel
of time series you know that would be a
heavy lift to get it to an episodic
uh tv show because that there's it's
packed with i mean this is packed with
detail like a stephen king novel is
and
so they did a good job with that and so
now all the tolkien crowd is taking a
little bit of sigh of relief
okay
maybe the amazon show on tolkien won't
be bad and it probably would probably be
good because god knows they're spending
what is it
million dollars on it or something i
mean it's an insane amount of money over
the series and so
you know maybe the production side the
studio side of amazon
especially with you know they've shown
what they can do with picking up uh
expanse and doing a very good job
and i think amazon as well have shown in
the past particularly they're not as
bothered about spending money in the
short term because they know they'll get
it in the long term
it's like it's a bit of an example of
like how they sold the fire sticks when
they was first getting amazon tv and
prime going they sold the fire sticks as
for cost they didn't make any money on
actually selling the the fire sticks
because they knew once they sold them
they'll make the money in the back end
and when those um the the first tablets
when they first came out with the
read on the fire things they did
themselves they sold them as cost they
were the cheapest tablet you could buy
yeah i mean
they'd make the money on the back end
yeah i mean i'm not afraid to spend the
money you know i got one the top end of
fire seven this little seven inch tablet
and
it was like 65 and when his color ran
apps had mail you know run you know i
could i can watch uh amazon tv on it or
the amazon prime excuse me and uh read
all the yeah and so they made the money
back on selling all the books they're
not stupid
they're not stupid and um and i i i'm
not necessarily worried about making
that the one thing with with stargate
adword i do want to go back to star trek
in a second but um you know the one
thing i am worried about stargate
is that what i'm being told anyway is
that they want to do this big thing
where it'll be the tv shows the movies
and the game and other things and these
will all be influence each other and go
into each other um but the game is
called timekeepers that's coming out and
we're going to see that first
um it should be at some time in the
summer and keith's getting put back
though um
but that apparently is about an sgt team
that is bouncing through time
and i'm like well if that's the
introduction to what amazon are planning
to do
then it's all going to be tiny why me
crap
and that's how they're going to get
around cannon they'll just say well we
changed time sorry oops sorry oopsie
um i'm not i'm not overly excited about
that but then again then if they do it
right
they need russell t davies
it's you know just talking about flux
doctor who flux do we want to even go
down that rabbit hole or
i tried to watch it but
i tried to watch the jody the jody wood
taker uh the first season and i couldn't
even get through it
you know i watched it i did watch it all
i mean you know it's i'm in for opinion
for a pound i guess with uh doctor who
but
[Music]
the problem is though i don't think
that's jody whittaker's fault because i
think jody whittaker is a brilliant
actress and i think
i i think it's a writing fault it's the
writer's fault yeah who hasn't been very
good for about six years
yeah um you could tell in the uk doctor
who used to have the christmas day six
o'clock episodes the special was every
christmas day six o'clock it was the big
thing bbc advertised it like crazy
running up to christmas
um they haven't done that for about five
years now i think it's maybe six years
now um it's been relegated to new year's
day
um is that is the new year's day doctor
who's special um i think that's a big
sign that they they knew the the viewers
have dipped and
that it's just not as good as it was but
the old showroom has come back as me so
maybe they'll
perk up
and they now they had so many great
female characters you know rose was such
a great character
and the girl from the guardians of the
galaxy movies
there was also a colored girl who was in
the time of rose
and she had married
one of the doctors companions they had
become
uh they were both dark british
yes i do know who you mean but i can't
remember her name
yeah and she was a good companion too i
liked her
but
you know and everybody forgets that
other girl from series four who worked
in an office
she was only in it in one david tennant
season
but she was like a woman
um no she's a comedian over here
oh oh god tate summit tate yeah
yeah
yeah she's actually quite a famous
actress over here she's a but she's a
comedian
she was great she only did the one
series
she was great when she um
but um but yeah i said i've never been a
big doctor i'm not a hoovie
i'm afraid i i like doctor who i watched
the matt smith and david tennant once
they were great
um as soon as matt smith went
i just stopped watching him
yeah i saw the peter capaldi stuff and
it wasn't as good as a matt smith and
for me it wasn't as good as david
tennant and matt smith
i felt like they just kept changing
things for the sake of it that's kind of
annoying that peter capaldi got better
in the second series apparently but at
first he was like an angry doctor and it
was or didn't he lose his memory or
something
i figured i did watch it a little bit
i was just
i'm just wondering if it was writing too
because it was
i thought the stories were just
there was one there there was one
uh
and it was with it starred the actress
who played arya stark
oh yes
oh god i can't remember the it was with
capaldi and that was a good story it was
shockingly good
and but then it was just the rest of it
was just you know i i'm beginning to
think that you know the combination of
i don't know the the cybermen and uh the
dialects are just have just played out
you had mentioned near oh the problems
of writing and i remember with the
capaldi season i think that guy called
moth
was uh
yeah the guy who took over after russell
t davies what did you say mom
target profit start wars reference
ignore me oh my turkey
yeah um
steve moffitt
steve moffitt and what he would do in if
you notice he'd do this a lot in
episodes he would make the problem and
then 10 minutes before the episode ended
the doctor would magically
fix everything like it would just
something would happen at the end and
everything would
get fixed that i remember reading online
that's what everybody's complaints about
the capaldi stuff was
yeah but i think stephen moffat was um
the only thing i'd say i like i liked
you know stephen muffet was in charge
but he was a comedy writer originally
that's what he did he was famously if he
did a series called coupling which is
like british friends and it was
brilliant it was very very funny
um but that's what stephen moffatt was
kind of known for um and then he tried
to he was a big fish in a small pond and
he tried to go over to america and do
stuff and then he was like a little fish
in a massive pond something and didn't
do so who came back but
um i
i i i like that but because he brought
the humor i think they tried to inject
humor into this peter capaldi that just
didn't work
um like the one thing he's like he rides
into it the bad guys in there there's a
fight or something going on and he rides
in on a tank with an electric guitar
just like oh yeah wow i'm saying i think
this is supposed to be funny
but it's just stupid
um
you know you want to hear a really cold
cold comment about the whole capaldi
doctor
yeah do you really want to hear this
okay so
the memes that came out of uh capaldi as
doctor who were funnier than doctor who
with
capaldi the memes were better
yeah that is sad doing it that's right
and you know and you're going to get all
the hate mail no one's going to send
hate mail to me they're going to send
hate mail to you but i think the memes
that i saw on facebook about
capaldi's doctor was uh was better than
capaldi's doctor yeah it's all about
opinion don't send me hate mail i'll
just delete it send it over here it's
all opinion
and you know
acting wise i don't think peter capaldi
really was a good co-star
like in terms of uh
entertaining you and bouncing off
stuff he wasn't a really a good co-star
for the the girl who was playing
impossible girl
and she was a really good character but
those two characters it it was almost
like why is she with
i couldn't really see her following the
peter capaldi doctor but i could see her
following the matt smith doctor
yes i can i can follow that yeah it's
accuracy was always the relationship
there was there
the relationship the way they wrote it
you know
there was always kind of a like a little
bit of a will they won't they sort of
thing going on there with the pete with
the uh with the previous ones and with
river and then they're going in here and
maybe obviously now he's an old grandad
maybe
that's crazy because when keith peter
capaldi was named i was like get in
again he was in a show over here in the
uk and he was very popular and he played
a very aggressive swearing politician's
aid thing and it was he was brilliant in
it i was just like yes that's fantastic
idea let's do it and then actually when
it was on it was like oh no this was a
terrible idea what were they thinking
it's all gone wrong
um but yeah
let's see what they do with it
it'll disappear from my tv screens again
i think surely
but if you guys want to see some really
good sci-fi
on netflix there's a show called love
sex and robots
did you see that scene i've never
watched it
oh
it's a bunch of shorts
it's different like shorts oh it's a
short anthem oh it's a short one but
like black windows ah okay
um
i i have read that it's really good but
i've never got around to watching it
it'll blow you away
i'll have to give it a go i read a
couple things about one or two of the
episodes actually got a lot of people
got very angry
about one or two of the episodes
and um oh really
yeah yeah but you know that's
no but you know
they they all make you think
yeah i think that's what probably is
what got people angry some people don't
like thinking they don't be like being
poked into thinking
um they like to um just eat popcorn and
order things off amazon and not
think too much and just don't look up
yeah don't look up
yeah but i think that i think that's
true i think people when they get
provoked into thinking they get they
just get confused and then annoyed
um
but but yeah no i i will i will tank
your on that one i will try to watch it
when i get a chance i was going to ask
you though you know talking about what's
coming in 2022 get back to star trek a
little bit
um strange new worlds
give a crap about that in the slightest
i'd love to see it
really i'm really not interested
how about you aliens in space what do
you think
uh
that's the new star trek animated show
right that's prodigy that's prodigy and
this is the one that's got captain pike
um on the old enterprise on the
enterprise day
oh
but they haven't released the trailer
for this one right we've really sweep
that we've seen a couple of little
things but not a great deal they have
finished production they have finished
filming
and they did some refilms so that'll be
it should be out in april i think so
we've seen a bit of promo stuff but not
a proper i don't think we're going to
proper advert we've seen like interview
things with little snip bits
you know if it's made uh by these new
people
i'm really not interested because i'm
such a you know and
i've liked all the areas of star trek
but
these new star treks
yes they have great special effects
but the dialogue and the characters are
really tone deaf you know
and i mean for me you know watching it
because i watch a show like caprica
you know or battlestar galactica
and i loved caprica you know i loved
caprica i'm not all about the action you
know um
and
there's shows that had great characters
great writing you know and diverse and
and stuff like that but
uh
these star trek shows the the way the
dialogue comes out is kind of weird you
know
it's really weird and they're supposed
to be like kind of military it's so far
off from
you know voyager deep space nine
and i like the abrams movies so i
but those are my thoughts you know it's
okay we'll talk about the abram movies
then because those films make me quite
angry so oh yeah
as films i think they're great
is it an actual film this is a future
episode i've got a from future video is
called why the jj april movies suck okay
it's gonna be the title um
or why they're stupid to make me angry
it's again it comes down to as a trekkie
i'm a bit
geeky on the technical stuff
i like i've actually read you know the
ncc 170 technical manual
and you know and i and i like all this
geeky stuff
um
so why
on earth
did jj abrams do
um the the long-range transporters which
make transporters irrelevant
they could have just transported those
torpedoes to them to chase khan when
they knew where he was they didn't need
to send the enterprise
um because they've got long-range
transporters apparently stop making
sense
the warp drive of the enterprise made no
sense the warp core it's just it seemed
to be hydroelectric from as far as i
could tell
um from the science of it you know it's
just like why did they
why did they mess around with it so much
why did the enterprise look completely
different every episode and why was it
like 10 times bigger than any other
starship that had come before it
it just
i don't know it's a film as not a star
trek film i really enjoyed them i
thought they were really good action
movies
quite funny
there's a star trek film they may drive
me up to war
because yeah not star trek
as far as i'm concerned yeah i i think
the most realistic use of spaceships
like in a show or in a movie
has been the expanse
uh lately like
totally agreed yeah i agree with you
totally
i can't think of but you know i was
watching uh a joe rogan podcast with an
astronaut he was saying when he comes
back down he's got to be in bed for like
six months
because the human body isn't meant for
space
yeah
and it's weird because
they say that if we're gonna be
traveling in light speed and stuff in
the future
it might not be
people in human bodies
it might be some sort of hybrid they
make like some sort of
cyborg
type okay clone
and that modifies more for space sort of
thing
that makes sense you know the the space
station up above us is
spinning
really quick faster than a speeding
bullet
you know
okay that's the international space
station
i mean yeah the international space
station is is orbiting the planet but it
is not the yeah that's itself i think
anything about elon musk is planning on
building a one of his starships is need
to have a
tubular thing with a little straight
really fast to create centrifugal force
will create gravity
um but it works
the you know the movement of the space
station above us
uh
that space station it looks like it's
still
but it's actually spinning
super super quick like a top all right
i gotta i gotta i gotta say no on that
it physically is no
no structural integrity uh if it did
that the structural integrity of iss
would it would it would fling the solar
panels off
but i don't think it spins
no it does not spin
now there's
[Music]
about just to move that's the expense
the why episode of the expanse i
absolutely loved was during the episode
i think it was early in the second
series
they had the episode where they he you
know the engine that they use and
there's the guy on the the rocket and he
accidentally
gets it and he just gets thrown back and
it just the rocket just goes shooting
off sort of thing
um and he can't get back because the
fuel runs out it's just a standalone
episode that character never appears in
it
it's it's a bit odd at the time
thinking what the bloody hell is going
on but
the engines were accidentally designed
so i think i loved that episode and most
sci-fi
apps wouldn't do that they wouldn't
throw in it's a completely random
episode right in the middle of um thing
i'm sure it was the second series but
i'm not sure
um
a brilliant little episode
yeah made no real didn't really add a
great deal to the story
um but it really just added like depth
to the the universe sort of thing
um i i i think the expanse is massively
underrated
it is a as a as a tv series as a
franchise really the first series in
particular was excellent
um
and you know
if you guys really like sci-fi also on
netflix there's another anthology
and it's made uh you know love sucks and
robots is made by darren aronofsky's
team
like darren aronofsky and the guy who
directed deadpool
one
uh got together and they got filmmakers
they knew and each short is like a movie
pitch
but there's another one uh by the by
neil blow camp the me the guy who made
district nine and he made his own
it's called oat studios
oh i don't know
that's actually yeah i've seen bits of
that that that was good actually i did i
did like that and then
district nine is one of my
favorite sci-fi movies
of sort of that er i just love i love it
when a film surprises you every so often
that um yeah they just go right that's
what people are making but i'm going to
make something completely different and
people have it you always know where the
film's good when people copy it
and um it's been copied a few times
since so i think although you know the
idea or the style has been copied a few
times since
you know saying it's um now that that's
that's an excellent movie
and um
as i say you're surprised from beginning
to end
you have no idea where that film's going
and then you know talk about um sci-fi
should have layers to it
there are so many different ways of
looking at that film and and maybe
trying to see what the what what they're
trying to tell us you know like i mean
obviously
there's things about racism and
um
economic poverty and all this sort of
thing there's there's so many different
lines to it
i love that film it's absolutely
excellent
so when did we decide on strange new
worlds for star trek then are we are we
excited about that or no i'm talking
about i'm gonna you actually want to
watch it but why do you want to watch it
stormy
why why why anything i'll i'll watch
anything star trek i mean you know it is
always
you know it's always an opportunity for
them to get back on track you know
the the
uh i love christopher pike as a
character i think the actor does a very
good job of portraying him it is
and i'm really curious
where
he takes that character
you know and um
now whether
the writers in the studio can pull it
off who knows but yeah i'm kind of it's
a
it's
i'm just really curious about it
i suppose i'm more curious that i'm
excited but i just think it's another
opportunity to mess up canon
it is a total new opportunity to screw
it up does my heading i don't want to
see another prequel i want to see
star trek the next generation 20 years
on
i want to see
you know i think that's why i was quite
excited when discovery went into the
future and i was like oh we'll see we'll
see something in the future that'll be
good and then there's the burn oh
another brood immediately
and you know it's like um
enterprise was also really good that
show enterprise
yeah i loved enterprise it's great
i watched but uh the first two episodes
both broken bow last night
oh broken bow yeah that's a great
well one of the things i love about that
show is that they really spent some
money
on on the particularly broken bow and
then the first couple of episodes
um but the the relationship between the
humans and the vulcans i just love that
i thought it was so clever
it needed like three more seasons
i wanted to see i've got a i got for
christmas a model of the enterprise
um but it comes with the um you know the
extension they were planning so the
refit
so that made it look a bit more like a
constitution so it actually had like um
a drive section
so i'm just trying to decide do i build
it original or do i build it with the
drive section
it's like oh decisions i might have to
put a pole up on just
people i think
i think i'm going to build it with drive
sections just looks stunning for the
drive section
i haven't built it yet i got it
i haven't even looked at it to be honest
i'm so busy
um
i'm really so i've decided to um
i am going to do this like fan fiction
of stargate
um and i've actually can tell you that
what won
so because i did a poll say what what
what sort of storylines you want me to
do and um a new sg team got 39 and an
ancient storyline got 37
so i've decided i'll do both
um so i'm going to merge the two and
i've actually had a really interesting
idea of another subscriber how to do it
so i'm that's how i'm going to do that
and so i'll talk about that in a bit but
interesting i suddenly realized i'm
really busy how the hell am i going to
do this
i'm going to do this
um and then the wife is like when like i
i i don't know i'll start getting up
early or something i don't know but i'll
have to make it work um
she also pointed out that i can't write
or spell
so um
so i'm just like we'll figure it out we
support though yeah now she was
supportively telling me i can't spell
um and i was like that's what the
computer's for the computer tells me
when i spell something wrong you put a
red line under it so
but um i was like my grammar isn't
amazing my sons mock me repeatedly
because every so often i go what's a
semicolon for dad and i'm like you know
i don't know so why are you asking me
um but i'll figure it out we'll get
there um but so that's what we're going
to do i'm going to do a new sg team
and there's a billboard but there'll be
an ancient storyline
intertwined with it and uh
there you go i'm announcing it that's
what we're doing
all right
since we were talking about star trek
there is a game on the playstation vr
and i think it's on the oculus of star
trek and
you command the bridge or you could be
any any spot in the in the bridge you
know
the captain the the lieutenant wharf and
you could be next-gen or original
trilogy
and you can actually go and fight the
klingons the borg and everything if
you're a star trek fan
i'm gonna tell you
you have to play the the vr
the vr bridge commander years ago dude
you have all the best toys man he does
i'm really jealous and they had bridge
commander years ago didn't they on the
uh one of the playstation 2's or
something i know it's on the pc that was
really cool but it was never big enough
they weren't the game wasn't so the
technology wasn't there but and nowadays
i'm thinking just that's what i want
it's just you keep seeing the star trek
game on the um on the phone
and then i actually thought that's going
to be rubbish and but it kept getting
advertised keep an eye out so brent
spiner does the advert for it now so
i've got to go and i actually went on
that because this is awful
it's just that stupid thing where you
have to like press ding ding ding ding
doesn't actually do anything because i
mean if you want to do something cool
give me money
you said you were free i played that it
was bad it was
that's disappointing yeah it was it was
very i thought a new ad is like you know
download now and get the free michael
burnham upgrade
whatever the hell that is the adverts
are much much much better than the game
the brent spiner
and will riker adverts are hilarious
they're very very good but the game is
terrible
remember that there was another game
that was like that you had to buy your
way to victory it was uh had arnold
schwarzenegger as the one of the uh
he was always in the ads and it was like
um like
rain or something or something i don't
you
know and he had the remote control and
his head on a remote control car cool
move he won't believe that yeah it was
like on your phone and it was really hot
and heavy in 2017
i think it was 2016 2017 and it was a
miserable playing experience
they made buckets of money but it's just
a miserable playing experience they've
made loads of money in all these games
over there because they suddenly realize
that actually people will pay like 30
pence
a thousand times but they won't want to
pay 30 pounds yeah they don't like
paying it all in one go but if we get
them addicted
and it's easy so you think you're
getting somewhere
and but as soon as it starts asking me
for money i just that's what i just need
that lollipop crate and i can rule the
sector that little shot of endorphins
but you've done it 100 times
let me tell you the the vr game you
could be on it the the whole day i'm
telling you it's it's that great it's
not like the
mobile phone game i had i played the one
you were talking about is really bad
really boring uh
but here it gets you because you're
playing with other people on your bridge
and you get to talk to them and
i'm going to tell you you'll love it you
guys will it sounds amazing i have to
admit it but as as a man with children
my children will never let me on it
so um unfortunately i'll never actually
get a go but uh no it that sounds like
the sort of game of the vr
would be amazing and that you can
actually walk up to the console and you
can actually
you know think that that would be pretty
cool i want to see the questions uh
mobile strike
mobile strike yeah of course it was it
was um like like risk
not like risk
command and conquer it looks a bit like
yeah yeah kind of like that you know
one's in a sector and you build missiles
and you know you get resources you steal
them from other people you build jeeps
you build a better jeep
you increase your technology you know if
you get you know if you want to upgrade
all this and
and cut down your resource time or your
building time for your artillery
whatever you just oh just a dollar
either we're going to upgrade your
missiles three days or give me 30p
exactly
mobile strike oh you can buy this pack
for a thou that gives you a thousand
gold and it's only 99 pounds
like that's a bargain let's do that no
okay i'm saying if you are doing that
you're an idiot
um i'm sorry i've got better things to
do in my life
than than spend hours on it unless they
i've got
way too much to do as it is a full-time
job
doing this and now apparently i'm
writing a book i
really don't know why i did that but um
no there isn't enough time the day to
play games oh dude this uh this next
year is just gonna be jam-packed it's
just good lord
yeah
i need a really good
covid to happen again so that we can
have a lockdown i didn't take advantage
of it first time around see i'm
realizing
i did not take advantage
um i i did i watched lots of telly
i could have done could have done so
much
you know uh i i was gonna tell you guys
that if stargate gets rebooted again i
hope that they do something
with
like what's happening today with like
the tic tac ufos
and
you know all the i i hope because brad
wright was saying oh
that he if he made a new star trek
series it would be i mean a stargate
series it would be about how stargate
would uh
affected the world like the world knows
about stargate secret yeah and so would
that affect technology would they be
seeing more ufos they could do so many
visual
stories you know so
that relates today
the thing i like about that it is is
that that you could tell i i like
conspiracy theory um i did used to have
another channel or i still got another
channel that um i talk about mysteries
and things like this um
and i
i i love that but you watch stargate and
he's like whoever wrote this loves a
conspiracy theory as well because
they're all in it they're all they're
all intertwined through the series you
know it's like
reptilians and all everything was in it
um all the old ancient astronaut
theories they're all in stargate yeah
that's why you see where they go i loved
it all yeah exactly it's all intertwined
in there um so yeah things like the tic
tac and things that they would have to
do something like that wouldn't they
have to do like like it's some sort of
experimental new thing and they
accidentally got caught on camera or
something that after they you could see
them having a joke about that guy that's
the sort of thing they would
you could see richard dean anderson
making a little sarcastic comment
about
about he got caught sort of thing
yeah
that was discussing
like a new path
of how um
stargate could go or was did i read it
some places like
the next series should be
the disclosure going along with all of
this you know what if the next stargate
series
disclosed well okay humanity we got this
thing in the ground
it's kind of interesting we've spent a
[ __ ] ton of money on it
and was it you and i discussing in a
previous video or something about what
if that that was the new gist of the
gateway of the of the
of gate world and so to speak was just
disclosing i don't remember no i don't
think it was us but it could have been
gonna be um i do think that's
interesting but my
my worry about that is a big thing about
stargate is that it like it could be
happening
so it was like you know that the whole
stargate program could be happening
right now and we don't know so it could
be real sort of thing
if it's if if it's based sort of 15
years or nearly 20 years now after sg-1
ended we've got all these starships
and you know we've got all this
technology we've got the ancients
technology bloody um atlantis is sat in
the middle of san francisco bay at the
end of stargate atlantis
and no one noticed um
we've got the asgard technology we've
got the asgard core you know it's like
so our technology is gonna be
quantum leaping
is stargate just gonna become star trek
is it stargate anymore
you know i thought that made sense
though the fact that you know they're in
contact with the
the thor people the art the asgard
people you know uh they've been
discovering these things so
you know their technology would affect
uh
the earth technology
i i thought that in stargate that made
sense you know the fact that they had
gotten their ships and
uh that they weren't only using the
stargate you know because they were
going all these worlds they were bound
to that that technology was bound to
change their world but i see what you're
saying like is it going to turn into a
ship show you know just like a show
about ships and stuff i get you yeah and
it says i just think the technology has
got to a point especially remember now
we're going to be 20 years on again
that it's it's
we've got star trek for that
the stargate was something different it
was a little bit different i know it
even when we had the starships they were
still secret
we weren't and they weren't very good
compared to everybody else you know we
couldn't go toe to toe with
with anybody you know we got our asses
handed to us if we tried
um you know the the original the first
couple of um uh ships that we had um oh
god i forgot the name of them the x-303
and then
the daedalus
they still had missiles
yeah you know that we were still using
missiles that was the rails
yeah the deadlifts got destroyed they
didn't it got them it got it got
its ass on egypt by um by a gold world
mothership
and um but it said fire missiles at this
thing and then you just go
and blows it out of the sky you know
it's like um
one thing that sargent always had for
going for it is that
we were struggling
we were newbies and we knew it
you know and it was the struggle
part of it i think the formula was the
struggle the human struggle to overcome
these obstacles of [ __ ] we had no idea
about i think that was part of the story
and even going back to the original
movie it was the struggle like i think
they um they knew that as well because
they really played update if you think
about the episode the knox in the first
series
when we go to this planet where there's
supposedly this this this creature that
can disappear and the gold world have
been trying to capture one for
generations and they can never capture
it so we've got the sgt and go thinking
oh this is a technology maybe we can use
and they find this knocks people and
they think they have to protect the knox
because they seem like simple
nature folk and then it turns out
actually they're one of the original
four species and they're incredibly
advanced and we we don't need they don't
need our protection you know it's the
other way around something
i think that was the whole premise of
the show really so that we were these
you know we were taking baby steps out
into the universe and we knew nothing
um
i i like that asgard when we have the
replicators and they say no we'd have
never thought of having lead projectiles
being thrown out of a goodnet thing you
know your child-like thinking is what's
what we need
um and it's
like you're so stupid it's what we need
but that was the kind of the whole
premise of the show when it wasn't that
we're so stupid
um and and so technologically inferior
but we
were still fighting still battling on
and still succeeding
everybody loves an underdog don't they
you know they
do i want to see some of the new
characters to be related to the original
characters i always think you mean like
um like uh
amanda tapping's daughter or something
like that i i i would really like to see
in the news if they do a new stargate
series particularly if they do an
academy i'd i'd love to see if they
could get back some of the characters
from that foothold episode some of the
young
trainees sort of thing maybe in some
some role as whether it be mages or
something by now i suppose but i i think
that would be interesting i want to see
the character rush come back and just
[ __ ] slap everybody i mean he was just
because he was such an ornery guy
but who was ruddy
you know from stargate universe the
crazy scientist that didn't explain
anything to anybody
oh yeah yeah super supposed to mean i'm
just trying to read this comment so it's
always been my contention that all the
secrets of space travel in aliens could
not be kept secret from the public since
many are in the know
and and he's i think william's bang on
there to be honest that um
it's too much how do not talk about bob
lazar
you
we've had this discussion a few times
lately
about bob lazar and aliens
i i i think he's bang on though that
that if the stargate program was true
you imagine like the battle over
antarctica
that would have been noticed even though
it's over antarctica but still would
have noticed
you know somebody would have seen that
[ __ ] elon musk could know
or maybe he's an alien
or maybe elon musk built the ships in
his secret boundary and wherever
you heard what's going on in switzerland
what's going on in switzerland they're
making a lot of chocolates
you guys were talking about uh elon musk
but
they're gonna come out with a neuralink
and in switzerland they have cyborg
parties where people get implanted with
their chips
and they become uh
it's a popular thing now they're having
these cyborg parties you know and you're
able to pay for things with your thumb
you know you have chips in your thumb
and your head no that's true
um it's
um there was about sixty percent of the
population have already been implanted
in switzerland they used it as their
keys everything that's 60
it was really um pushed on with covered
and nobody wanted to touch anything
and so this technology thing but you can
open your door with it you can do
everything
the uh the the guy that came up with
that kind of technology he was a british
researcher he was the first guy to get
chipped he was on cover of wired
magazine [ __ ] sometimes i've been
sticking any dogs for 20 years man it's
not well yeah it's not new technology
he was a british university professor
they came up with that idea dude we do
everything good in the world
baz has joined us i do fascinate you and
age me versus a bear
um
i just love that yeah i just love that
everything evil in the world um is
british
we're really good at it and then other
countries take it and do awful things
with it but we've done everything else
at concentration camps we invented those
you're welcome um
does everything awful tanks we did that
um
i just think you know rule britannia
you're all welcome
you you know what at least in britain
for you know women have rights
you know
you don't see slavery in britain you
know
we uploaded mate we invented it and then
outlawed it and it exported it thank you
very much we let everybody else do it
and then we went yeah we're too good for
that and we said no no more and then we
gave women the vote
i've always told my wife i was just i
sat there we were talking about
something about the suffragette movement
biggest mistake this country ever made i
didn't even get the sentence out she
knew i was going to say she punched me
really hard
i'm always trying to wind her up she's
very easy to wind up my wife um but i'm
always trying to wind up i didn't even
get the sentence out and she hit me
gotta love it now but i think we've
we're a country that punches above our
weight
i think we're quite proud of it as well
i had little family
that went to london
they liked it a lot
it's a beautiful city mate you should
yeah yeah definitely come on over and i
say we've never lost a conflict ever
we've won every single war we've ever
been involved in
um
ish and um
you're americans i'm saying
you you guys you guys want to laugh
right what's
what's one movie okay that one famous
classic this is a classic movie
classically okay
a classic movie
um that is not correct that you can't
really say that you like now is zulu
remember sulu with michael oh shoots you
shoot see the whites in their eyes
yeah yeah
it's just starting to look like
not particularly accurate either in lots
of ways oh really oh
there's a lot there's quite a bit of it
that's wrong but um
i thought
why would that be a problem now though
to be fair um we kind of had a mutual
respect by the end of it
well you know in the zulus in the actual
sulu movie with michael kane they were
uh they were in the actual battle the
guys that you see in the actual movie
are like the sons and daughters of the
people of the actual battle or something
like that
yeah there are some of their own but it
was actually filmed at the the place as
well uh some of the rich oh god i can't
remember that's terrible
i should know my british history better
than this
but it's a great movie it's a great
movie it's a great movie um the prequel
as well that the um dawn of zulu or
something like that that's when uh the
worst british military defeat pretty
much in history where they all came in
and they just took all our guns we have
another guest we can invite a fourth
person on if you'd like to invite a
fourth person on bring him on
why not
comment hello
hello where are you from
okay we're gonna get rid of that guy
[Laughter]
it was ahmed plus one
but it was
you know i was saying in terms of action
you know get me kicked off youtube you
[ __ ]
sorry call me
jesus that guy's right uh but the
germans built large rockets in world war
ii that guy's right
v1 v2
then
the german fellow went over to america
and built big rockets
you want it you want to hear something
really scary that's a conspiracy theory
you know who werner von braun is right
yeah
you know he wrote a book about mars yep
i forgot to take two minutes ago
tomorrow that's what you wanted to do
i did not know that werner von braun
wrote a book about mars
and you know what he said in the book
about mars
he said that a man called elon will take
us there
and i i didn't know that i'll have to
google that later that's interesting he
was obsessed with mars he wanted to he
the only reason he wanted to go to the
moon was because he thought he could get
us to mars
yeah so um
he was obsessed with it um
he was uh the mars project right the
tech i love
written by
for a human expedition to mars it was
written by ron braun in 1948
and in the book he says that a man
called elon will take us there
i'm going to google that because that's
true that's awesome
to be honest because it's weird how did
you know that
yeah sometimes some of these things i
mean they they've got on memes on
facebook and people start thinking
they're true then when you look into it
it turns out not to be true but hey i if
it's true i will tip my hat to you that
is a wicked one i love it
um and he
will i have to read the book though i
haven't read the book
no i like how we love moscow when when
we go to mars i'm basically going to be
able to create all the laws myself and
people went crazy like what what they're
like well it's true they can just start
again so there's all these massive thick
lore books that we've got we can just
throw them out
and we can actually like have something
sensible well there was that again
there was a um
elon musk did a uh kind of a lengthy
podcast with
lex friedman i think uh last week and he
brought that up and he says i'm not
making the laws that's up to the
martians
yeah well he's even said he's not going
doesn't he more than once so um that he
won't be there so
anyway
we should start talking my sci-fi really
i can't even remember what we were
talking about last we took my stargate
again weren't we
see that's the thing about sci-fi it
it's relating so much you know sci-fi is
a mixture of reality
um
but yeah
the best sci-fi is though isn't it so
we've seen things like high post brazil
in reality now i actually think sci-fi
though has got a lot transformers i
think
people the general public think
a lot more should be possible than is
something people they don't understand
why well why don't we just go to moon
and was like because it's
technologically really hard he goes yeah
but surely we can do that can't we and
it's just like well
yeah but it's really hard something and
then i think people just assume things
should be oh god we've got another
person here i'm not
sam and something okay if this turns out
to be poor again i'm going to lose my
mind
maybe sam gamgee
sam something i i didn't care
quickly enough but sam if you want to
come back on and
you're not going to turn into people
remember sam keep your dick to yourself
please if you wouldn't mind
um i actually put a thing up saying
please don't swear
that was much worse
dude i think swear i'm sorry i've sworn
a couple of times as well i was the
first one to do so i won't worry about
it too much
but yeah i'll just um the best sci-fi
though do they like bleed into reality
it's supposed to be science fiction
you know so um it should should be
grounded in some sort of reality okay
cynthia you want to talk about the elon
thing a little bit more go on then you
read about avenue quoting from the book
chapter 24 how mars is governed states
the martian government was directed by
ten men the leader of whom was elected
by universal suffrage for five years and
entitled the elon
two houses of parliament enacted the
laws to be administered by elon and his
cabinet or by the elon in his cabinet
it's like a title
yeah but that's still pretty terrifying
okay the author is werner von braun
illustrator chelsea botswana gives the
uh publication date of 2006.
i am sorry i doubted you sir
um just because that was so incredible
it sounded like bs but yeah it's true
sometimes
you know it's one of those things like
fiction you know reality strange in the
fiction sometimes how mental is that
third of one point i think i'm traveling
weird
okay hang on hang on a second hang on a
second
okay so it's credited to the authors
credited werner von braun
a project mars a technical tale this
this book it's a different book than the
other it's a 2006 science fiction novel
by german american
rocket physicist werner von braun
1912-1977
credited
as dr verner von braun it was written by
von braun in german in 1949 and entitled
mars project
that's crazy but then it's based on the
other uh another book that von braun
wrote in 1953
called the mars project
i think it requires more deeper
scholarship
yeah we'll have to get into that i need
to i need to know
yeah
so it was okay so von braun wrote this
science fiction novel in 1948 but it
wasn't published
until 2006
it included technical papers on his
proposed project in paintings by chelsea
bondstell
in can publish in canada so
deeper scholarship but yeah i think i
think it's
that's crazy that's just working it's
just it's just mental honestly it's just
like what a wonderful world we live in
that as that is the case i love it it's
fantastic
um iron sky was one of those films that
i watched
um and it's so bad it's brilliant
um and i just love when films come along
like that every so often it's it's like
a proper classic b movie you know that
we used to get in the 50s yeah like them
and it and all those films it's just
wonderful and it's just sort of like
it's just halfway through it just goes
we're not even halfway through from the
very beginning the film we just went
we're doing what the hell we like in
this film um
and we're just going to go crazy and
it's just glorious it's just one of
those and they've made about five of
them haven't there's there's a few
i've never seen all the others two
answers in sequels but um the original
classic brilliant film
so what i saw the original it was good i
liked it
i have we have somebody else called sam
is going to join us we'll let him join
and see we think god i'm ready with the
turn off button just in case though sam
the man however sam hello
never doing it again oh god oh god oh
lord jesus
okay from now on i'm not getting
anywhere
i'm having a good time no one else is
joining
i think i've realized why this was um
when no one else does this stormy
inviting other people you don't know one
but you know i'm actually subbed to a
couple of other youtubers and for some
reason yesterday they were using stream
yard too
it must be like a new thing or something
it's been a couple of years but it's
free
yeah so you can do it without him it's
it's quite hard to get on live youtube
the actual live
thing that you can use through youtube
is isn't very good
um and you can't have you can't bring
other people on like this but you can
with streamyard um but you can do it
free this way you just have to have the
little yoga logo in the top corner so um
but yeah it's it it works
i think it's why it's probably people
are picking on it and you know it's
getting views more
more popular something um if you if you
pay for it you can have the stream your
thing took off but
it works perfectly well so
so
2022 is coming on us then so we're in
the last a half hour or so of the chat
before um i go to bed
so it's a half 12 here and i'm old so
that's really late for me
um
a couple of projects are coming up in
the next 12 months so i've written
myself a list
we've already mentioned the lord of the
rings
two minds about that they're spending a
crapload of money on it so let's see
what happens
but we've got um
there's the house of the dragon prequel
the lord and game of thrones prequel
i want to watch that
i think that'll be good i'm quite
looking forward to that um
one of the things i've got i've just
done a video on um firefly right and
then remaking firefight because now
disney owned firefly
and one of the comments i made was
disney uh a brilliant squeezing every
last drop of blood out of every product
they own
they will squeeze that stone starfleet
academy good t-shirts
they will squeeze that until they get
everything out of it right
for example star wars projects this year
this year
obi-wan kenobi
and which i'm actually quite looking
forward to i think that'd be quite cool
rangers of the new republic lando and
ashoka are all new tv series coming out
this year that's
four
and five sorry because thingy just came
out booker um bob
the book of boba fett
i think five new tv series when they
have 12 month period
they're gonna squeeze
until like every last drop of blood out
of the star wars um franchise
um
but but you know that
you know what happened over at disney
was
they they're investors
started getting mad the dis the star
wars investors
because all the star wars merchandise
started going down after last jedi
like last jedi did really good in the
box office but people weren't buying
uh the star wars merch
so they had to change things do people
still buy merch don't really
and there's a lot of style it's on low
it's on everything isn't it to be fair
yeah
i went to a show that we have um
a
christmas in the uk these shops but i
don't know if the same in the us but
these shops pop up that just sell lots
of toys basically and they sell lots of
um
hologram lights and
light up speakers and all sorts it's
called mankind the one that we've got
over here at the moment
and that's to prefer star wars is on
almost everything
you can sell by some it's marvel and
star wars is on everything
you know yeah um
but i mean i just think
i i think it was solo for me
that really solo really oh it's like a
kick in the ball solo
it was like the entire franchise
literally ran up and kicked me squarely
in the balls oh the all the way through
i like solo
god you've got to be i don't know
how do i take them okay i know okay so
my comments about solo it really should
have been titled chewbacca i think we
can all agree on that because it was
more i think it had more to do
i mean i was more jazzed about
chewbacca's story frankly than han
solo's
i mean i just think they they cocked it
up from the beginning though because the
guy they got playing solo wasn't very
good and
um the chick from game of thrones should
never have been in it we've got somebody
else appearing and i'm not
ocean man
no i don't think so
i'm sorry ocean man if you're still
watching i don't trust you in it
i don't want to see anyone
as it is i might have a youtube channel
in the morning um
but um ocean man if you want to leave
put a couple of comments up and say
hello and then i might i might join let
you join
um
what was i saying uh
[Music]
i think i've got just a second sorry
i'll be with you i've got to seek i've
got a private chat well why you got this
private chat going on i'll mention
something this has been a private
session i don't blame you the way uh the
disney corporation is going with all
these new shows for 2022 for the star
wars properties i think if they keep
going they're going to be down to like
you know having shows like chewbacca's
barber
you know or r2 d2s you know
maintenance supervisors adventures in
the shop or whatever
it's just
what the hell will be left
exactly yeah
well we'll know the whole universe
anyway
this is a really interesting point i
think here that williams made
what do you think would happen if the
james wood telescope actually found
evidence of alien life which is really
possible this james telescope is capable
of some really
we're going to be able to see into the
atmospheres of other planets
yes what do you think would happen
sci-fi if all of a sudden it became side
fact
i think there's things that they haven't
released
have you heard of the seti signal
yes yes of course yeah the
weird oh god
i can't remember what what did you write
in the
column
oh my god or something what was it
called oh god oh the wow signal that's
what
we wrote
signal that carl sagan
broadcasted out of uh puerto rico oh
right the wow signal the wow oh okay
wow yeah
yeah and it's happened a few times since
we've had a few signals since that we
can't quite explain
um and there's um they've got these
ultra high energy signals at the moment
that they they can't quite explain
um
that we keep getting hit bombarded by
and then we've got that star
that
um
that they think might be a dyson sphere
and because the luminosity of the snark
is going up and down in like a random
fashion like there's something very big
moving between us and the star
but it doesn't it's not right
nobody can explain it right right some
of the signals we've been getting um
uh i did a video on the boccinic
magnetar they found out that these are
like
strong magnetic pulses threat for some
reason uh neutron stars give out an
insane
large magnetic pulse
but that so that takes care of some of
these weird signals we don't think that
the wow signal was a magnetar spike
um there was one guy here in california
bocinic was his name is his name uh
found the first one that's naturally
occurring it
it's the same one it and it does
multiple of these
uh in the milky way so we finally found
one
magnetar in the milky way that repeats
and that from a physics point of view is
just
weird and insane
i think there's so much going to be in
the universe that we just don't
understand anybody that thinks we're at
a point where we know everything is just
fairly fairly
yes we have
yes um my other channel was called be
sister mystery we talk about this stuff
every week oh really oh okay i gotta
check that out
yeah i'll i'll put a link on one of
those but yeah we talk about this stuff
a lot um and bob lazar and aliens and
but i mean i i do think it's interesting
though that if
for one if you've got things like
um the roman catholic church has always
been really interested in telescopes and
they've got their vault that they don't
let anybody in if anybody knows if we if
ancient alien theory is true it's the
it's the roman catholic church in the
mountains
i'd love to get in there never mind
getting into
um area 51 i want to get into the
vatican vaults
yeah um i just want to read the bit that
says in the front of the bible this is
um
this is all fiction and shouldn't take
it too seriously the front page of the
bible they took out
um
but
i just think things like the james webb
telescope
screams to me that we're looking for
something
they're spending billions of dollars on
things like this they're not doing it
for no reason they're not doing it just
for science they're doing it for the
look because they're looking for
something
but the um the telescope on the south
pole really
makes me interested that is a very
expensive project to have that south
pole um
telescope it's not there for no reason
you know um
but like i said that what do you think
would happen to sci-fi then if this was
all proved to be
true
well it reminds me of a line from
firefly you know a wash is talking about
you know all the things that's going on
in that episode and it's like
it's just like science fiction and his
wife says honey you live on a spaceship
at some point in time yeah i mean there
is
i mean you you do is there a hard line
of what where science fiction ends is it
is it just a continuation of
new fiction that is based in science
where i think that's dividing line you
know the genre of fantasy is not based
in science
uh because if it is just based in is it
fiction based in science well that [ __ ]
can go on forever however we may be you
know
the stories may change depending on what
we know
i don't think like jill said
at all
jules verne was science fiction yeah and
then we went to the moon we went
under the oceans we
didn't actually go into the
underground bit we didn't do that bit
he's gone his mom must be of course
oh i didn't mean
he was great i hope he comes back
um
but you know jules verne was science
fiction at one point it's now you know
just a good book so yeah but you know
science fiction
even today even after we've gone to the
moon even after we're launching
spaceships
you know almost weekly now still science
fiction
yeah well exactly yeah i mean
there's so much in science fiction even
going back 20 years ago that is now
science factor we've surpassed i was
just thinking about the um
the computer on star trek even on the
next generation
and we're going oh my god that's that's
amazing and we've like surpassed it now
we've actually got computers that are
more powerful and much much smaller
you know the um the computer core and
the enterprise was enormous it was like
it was like six stories yeah and
absolutely massive
um our quantum computers aren't that big
that google are building you know it's
just like um so it's like we've actually
gone past that
um and we'll but i think science fiction
just evolves and it just changes and
it's always that whatever we know we'll
just imagine a little bit further right
i think
but that's a brilliant question really
interesting
um
the other couple of things that i was
just saying for 2022 that are coming out
that i am actually looking forward to
did you know they're doing a willow tv
series
i saw that i think it was what disney
day i think it was i know i can't
believe i didn't know until i started
looking at this i missed that
um i can't believe they're doing a
willow tv series i can't wait apparently
it's just it's a soft reboot it's
actually an extension it's going to be
like an extension to the film
so um you know what i'd like to see uh
back in the day um
george lucas produced it was a uh i
think he was directed t it was a tv [ __ ]
series that i never saw
it was on dvd for a while and it's
it was out of print
it was the young indiana jones
chronicles
i remember that shares and uh
i've always wanted to see it
and it was like after the show it had
like uh some sort of like educational
lesson or something where you could buy
or it had avail or lucasfilm was
producing like educational materials for
teachers about whatever
the the issue or the topic was of the
show
god i'd love to watch that
i would love it well we're going to get
geriatric indiana jones
in
2023 and 90 year old indiana jones with
his zimmer frame
right right right if he if he goes to do
any actual archaeology he's good he's
not going to kneel down to
to like pick anything up
so that's going to be an interesting tv
show a man can't run
how's that film gonna work i
don't know
um
on about films though
avatars coming
avatar two and then three four five and
six um it's gonna be the longest
pigging
sequel in history i can't remember how
long this just took
i'm not interested at all i actually
look at the list of movies that coming
up next next year on 2022 sci-fi movies
i'm not really interested in any of them
there's a couple of marvel films coming
out that'll be good
um i'm sure they're always good me and
morbius is coming out and um
love and thunder and things but actual
sci-fi films
were a bit bit thin on the ground
there's moon fall with um the new roland
emerick movie which is tends to be
quite good that seems to be like hollow
moon and all sorts so international
theorists will be happy but
yeah i am looking forward to the new
uh avatar
um
but in terms of like you know the the
marvel universe
i mean i like shin shi the some of the
things they had out this last year but
man it's just like
i really can't get in that emotionally
involved you know one now that you know
end game is over and it was literally
over
it's like the the that ark is missing i
mean i will eventually see you know all
the new offerings once they come to uh
to uh
yeah streaming
disney plus another reason of disney
it's been
it's been a crazy year thanks to
covington and things that everything
sort of got put back we've got a lot of
these tv shows and movies that we were
promised a long time ago we've still got
a lot of tv shows and movies that we've
been waiting on but not come yet
um we would probably have stargate on
our tv series now if it wasn't for covid
which is you know a huge shame
um
you know it's it's just
i'd love to see what's
i'm just looking forward to things to
get back to normal when they can
actually produce these things at a rate
that's
you know get back to not some sort of
normality but honestly this year i'm not
seeing anything that's exciting so that
you're doing the channel is going to be
great so i've got nothing to talk about
did you have you had a chance to see the
harry potter 20th year special i've
recorded it i haven't had a chance to
watch it yeah we've got to watch it with
the kids didn't we well i understand but
there's a
in the in the credits there's a whole
panel of credits just for the covid crew
the covet supervisor the
medic or whatever i mean it's just
a whole page just for the
coveted
crew for the i'm sure
and it's like god we've got and it's
just it never occurred to me i guess
yeah there's there's got to be some sort
of coven management on set
but anyway
it was very good to watch i really
enjoyed it yeah i'll probably try to
watch it tomorrow but um
and apparently when they're on set
they've all got these sensors that go
off if you get within two meters of the
other person when they're filming a lot
of these movies and things so um
i don't know all right but
i'm gonna call it a night
and well
because i'm so tired and um i've seen
far more willies this evening than i
intended to i hope i got them off
quickly enough that nobody was too
upset by that
why people do that i've god knows why
somebody's done that it's just stupid
but um and i'm going to i'll message
aliens and space later thank you so much
for joining me you were an absolute joy
so out here i look forward to seeing you
again
he had great toys man he was brilliant
oh man that man i i want his
his toy collection water water water
legend um ocean man please
jump on next time and we'll we'll have a
chat i i but i i lost my trust there i'm
gonna have to do something to try and uh
invite people on in future because i
love talking to people that we've never
spoken it's one of the joys about doing
this i i met you through
my old channel um somebody i would have
never met otherwise except other than
doing this youtube silliness
um you know and and i just love that
but you gotta take a risk sometimes and
i've also met a couple of nutters so
yeah
i'm just gonna check the private
messages before we spend an evening
ocean environment
dude i will definitely see you next time
motion map i really appreciate it i i do
think that uh 2022 is going to be it'll
keep us busy
you know i mean i think a lot of the
things
that we were discussing today you know
the the the disney offers the mcu you
know star wars et cetera et cetera i
think there's a lot of uh sci-fi stuff
that's coming up
that we just don't know about you know
uh there was one i've been wanting to
talk about this for the last two hours
and
i watched this one show
it was a korean sci-fi show called
silent c
um
never heard about it and it was on uh
netflix and it was uh
voiced over in english
and i had closed captionings huh
i think i watched it
it was about the lunar water
yeah i watched i think i watched that
yeah a while ago
well yeah it's been on a while but for
some reason suggested this a couple days
ago for me and so i just binge watched
the whole thing
and there's lots of little gems out
there that just kind of bubble to the
surface
the the really funny thing about that
show was if you have closed captioning
on
[Music]
the story's kind of completely different
it's like
a guy walks in and the audio the
voiceover says this place is a mess
the closed captioning is this room does
not have very good feng shui
literal literal uh yeah literal thing of
that is so if you ever if you're
watching
turn on the closed captioning like
they'll like the the voiceover will say
[ __ ] and then the closed captioning will
say [ __ ] and it was like dude pick one i
just you know you're excited okay you're
gonna die oh we get it just just
it's there so i think there's a lot of
nuggets that's coming up that we just
don't know about yet
yeah well that's a nice thing as well
about streaming and obviously the stream
is just spent over 100 billion of
content last year there's a war going on
yeah between streaming services and
that's only good for us
to be honest because it means they're
desperate for for
to get stuff on the screens
um we'll get some crap but we'll get
some gems as well and i think they're
getting
going i think they're more willing to
make it take a risk i think at the
moment because there is this
war going on
amazon netflix and you know i think that
they're willing to take a risk and see
what works
and things like
shows like firefly that on paper make no
sense
you know um somebody needs to take a
punt on it and
obviously it didn't work with firefly
but even so it's like the expanse maybe
um you know
you know somebody needs to take a risk
on that and i think we're going to see
shows that we wouldn't have seen
normally because
disney amazon
paramount plus when that hits the uk um
you know all these the all these
streaming services they're in conflict
with each other trying to try to get one
up on each other and yeah it's only good
for us and it's not necessarily that
disney plus or paramount plus is winning
no
i mean i think disney plus is doing
pretty well isn't it
because they're in conflict it keeps the
price down as well they're willing to
you know keep the prices down so
that's how that goes
amazon prime is doing my editing though
it's got so many of these channels now
that are um free to watch but they've
got adverts on and then they they're not
streaming but they've got there's loads
of them
yeah i'm just like well mgm you have to
pay 5.99 a month for the mgm channel and
that's where i start that's where they
put stargate
which is annoying
but i've got my dvd so yeah well there
you go well you know
years ago
uh right when they launched apple tv
i went ahead and just bought all of the
stargate and all of the star trek i
could at that time and the complete
series of x-files and a bunch of stuff
just you know
yeah because i actually i i had
go ahead
i said i don't buy dvds anymore because
of everything and now i just got disney
plug but fox
disney buying fox
save disney i had disney plus i thought
this is rubbish it's got nothing on it
the fox stuff come through and i'm like
actually there's there's loads on there
now including hex files
i love that i've been talking to us
again it was the first time in like 20
years since i've seen that
and then and actually i never watched
the end the last couple of series you
know the one with them
t2000 in it
i forgot his name
and when mulder and scully left anyway
and they added new characters for the
last couple of series oh watch those
they've watched them but i've watched
them next uh lucy lawless from xena
warrior princess was in there too yeah
yeah yeah oh yes i've forgotten about
that's actually yes but i'm watching
those now but
anyway it has been
emotional there's always stormy i
absolutely love talking to my resident
american thank you so much for joining
me very welcome this is always fun we
yeah we didn't have like a show it's
like you know
uh snotty old men and just hide like
that and it's just me you and some of
the others just get on and just [ __ ]
for every two hours on sunday yeah i
mean
naughty old man
my back hurts my knees
my wife is moaning at me
anyway it won't be riveting tv but we'll
enjoy it we'll enjoy it
okay for everyone that's just jumped on
and put a comment tonight thank you so
much really appreciate it for the guys
that put willy's on the screen thank you
so much
don't know why you did that what a
grow up
the astonishing thing they did not
belong to me no i hope they subscribed
though so that would be good at least i
got the view in minutes for something
great right
thanks so much guys and uh listen
everybody stay safe
go over and subscribe to um it looks
like you're my sister channel cy works
i'm sorry trek you side works that was
not intentional when i came up with my
name someone has to put the work in but
i immediately regret it i'm really like
crap i've done don't know i've made an
error sigh something that sounds
familiar that's good i'll do that great
i should do that yeah
yeah do that please go and find stormy
on his sideworks channel though it's
absolutely brilliant and you'll learn
lots of interesting things there's lots
of mysteries and stuff and you actually
get educated as well so go do that
because he's much cleverer than he looks
um trust me um for an american
i know i can fold paper
for people again
nobody's watching after an hour 45
minutes anyway so we're good
all right mate
stay safe everybody thank you we'll see
you next time thank you so much
good night night